>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR ARE
"SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT
ALREADY EXPLORE THE CULTURAL
STORIES OF THE DAY.
TO FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
RAYMOND ARROYO, AUTHOR OF "THE
WISE MEN WHO FOUND CHRISTMAS."
AN ONGOING DEBATE ABOUT THE END
OF THE FILM TITANIC AND WHETHER
JACK AND ROSE COULD HAVE BOTH
SURVIVED ON THAT FLOATING DOOR.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT SCENE?
>> SOME PEOPLE CARE MORE ABOUT
FICTIONAL CHARACTERS THAN REAL
PEOPLE.
I'VE NEVER HAD THIS
CONSIDERATION.
HERE IS KATE WINSLET 25 YEARS
AFTER ON THE CONTROVERSY.
>> I ACTUALLY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
WE WOULD HAVE SURVIVED IF WE HAD
BOTH GOTTEN ON THE DOOR.
I THINK THAT HE COULD HAVE FIT.
>> HE WAS ALREADY PRETTY WORSE
FOR THE WEAR.
>> IT WOULD HAVE TIPPED THAT IT
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN, IT WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN A SUSTAINABLE
IDEA.
>> I DOUBT IF HE WOULD HAVE FIT.
IT IS A DOOMED ROMANCE.
JACK WAS SUPPOSED TO DIE.
NOW JAMES CAMERON, THE DIRECTOR
OF TITANIC, WENT SO FAR AS TO
COMMISSION A STUDY ABOUT WHETHER
THESE CHARACTERS COULD HAVE
SURVIVED.
HIS ANSWERS, THEY COULDN'T HAVE
SURVIVED WHICH IS PROBABLY JUST
AS WELL.
CAMERON, WHILE PROMOTING HIS NEW
MOVIE AVATAR THE WAY OF WATER
RECENTLY SAID HE WAS "A WILD
TESTOSTERONE POISONED YOUNG
MAN."
I ALWAYS THINK OF TESTOSTERONE
IS A TOXIN THAT YOU HAVE TO
SLOWLY WORK OUT OF YOUR SYSTEM,
HE SAID.
CAMERON QUICKLY WORKED IT OUT OF
JACK'S SYSTEM.
HE DROWNED HIM IN THE THIRD ACT.
THERE YOU GO.
>> Laura: THERE'S A LOT TO BE
SAID ABOUT THAT, RAYMOND.
PROBABLY NONE OF IT ON A FAMILY
SHOW.
I MEAN, COME ON.
TOXIC MASCULINITY ALL OVER
AGAIN.
HAVEN'T WE GROWN WEARY OF THAT?
WITHOUT TESTOSTERONE, WOULD WE
HAVE PEOPLE?
>> LISA BOOTHE HAS AN
INTERESTING THEORY.
SHE THINGS ROSE IS THE VILLAIN.
SHE CHEATED ON HER FIANCE,
DROWNED HER BOYFRIEND, AND TOOK
THE DIAMOND.
PRETTY GOOD.
I HAVE THE WAY OF WATER EVERY
TIME I SEE A JAMES CAMERON FILM.
I RUN TO THE BATHROOM TWICE.
THEY ARE TOO LONG.
THERE WAS A SHIP WRECK AT THE
BOX OFFICE, THE AOC DOCUMENTARY
CALLED "TO THE END," CERTAINLY
FOUND THE END.
IT MADE LESS THAN TEN GRAND
THEATERS ON OPENING WEEKEND.
THE 75TH ANNIVERSARY OF "IT'S A
WONDERFUL LIFE" MADE $734,000.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOSH, AOC.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE SOUR
SUSSEXS.
MEGHAN AND HARRY WILL NOT STOP
THEIR LAME SELF-PROMOTION.
>> ONE DOES GET THE FEELING THIS
PUBLICITY RACKET OF THEORIES IS
JUST GOING TO KEEP GOING BUT IT
IS TO DRAW VIEWERS TO THE
NETFLIX SHOWS.
HARRY AND MEGHAN WANTS AN
APOLOGY, THEY WANT TO SIT DOWN
COME OF THIS NEW FOOTAGE
CAPTURES, KING CHARLES IS TAKING
ALL OF THIS.
SERIOUSLY.
OBVIOUSLY BROKEN UP ABOUT IT.
[CLAPPING]
>> Laura: I LIKE HOW THEY ARE
TRASHING THEIR FAMILY AND THEN
MAKING DEMANDS.
OKAY.
ANYTHING ELSE.
>> LIKE YOU HIT ME IN THE FACE
AND THEN ASK YOU TO BUY ME
DINNER AND THERAPY.
THE ROYAL FAMILY SAYS THEY ARE
BAFFLED BY THE REQUEST AND THEY
SAY IF ANYBODY IS GOING TO BE
DOING THE APOLOGIZING IT MAY BE
THE SUSSEXS.
>> Laura: MEGHAN SHOULD BE
APOLOGIZING FOR HER ACTING IN
THAT SHOW, SUITS.
THEY ARE TELLING US THAT WE HAVE
TO RUSH.
>> THE MEGHAN MARKLES ARE
ROLLING OUT THEIR NEXT NETFLIX
DOCUMENTARY ABOUT LEADERSHIP.
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE HARRY AND
MEGHAN'S DOCUMENTARY ABOUT
FAMILY COHESION AND
RECONCILIATION.
MAYBE IT CAN BE A HOLIDAY
SPECIAL.
FOR NOW, IT'S ALL ABOUT
LEADERSHIP.
>> IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MADE BRAVE CHOICES.
>> TO FIGHT FOR CHANGE AND TO
BECOME LEADERS.
>> GIVING INSPIRATION TO THE
REST OF US.
TO LIVE, TO LEAD.
>> NOT SURPRISINGLY, LAURA, THE
LONGEST REIGNING MONARCH,
QUEEN ELIZABETH, IS NOT PART OF
LIVE TO LEAD.
I GUESS SPENDING YOUR ENTIRE
ADULT LIFE IN SERVICE TO YOUR
PEOPLE IS JUST NOT ENOUGH.
YOU SAW GRETA THUNBERG.
GLORIA STEINMAN AGAIN, THEY MADE
THE CUT.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.
RAYMOND, I'M GLAD YOU WATCHED SO
WE DON'T HAVE TO.
SEE YOU LATER.
>> I HAVE A BIG ANNOUNCEMENT.
I KNOW I TOLD YOU THAT I HAD MY
TURNABOUT TAIL SERIOUS, NEXT
YEAR BUT AFTER WHAT WE WITNESSED
LAST WEEK ON THE SHOW, I'VE
WRITTEN A NEW BOOK.
THE INGRAHAM WHO FOUND
CHRISTMAS.
IT'S ABOUT HOW LAURA INGRAHAM
CAME TO LOVE LITTLE FAKE TREES
AND FOUND THE TRUE MEANING OF
THE SEASON THANKS TO HER FRIEND
RAYMOND.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW SOMETHING.
>> I WILL